je joue un caroline duchesne professeur
à l'universel aval au département de
biochimie microbiologie de
bioinformatique directrice du
laboratoire de recherche sur les bio
aérosols bonsoir madame jeanne bienvenue
à 24,60 écouté et je lisais ce matin
dans le devoir un article semble dire
qu'effectivement le lakovic 19 pouvait
se transmettre par des aérosols c'est
votre passion avoue les virus en aérosol
vous avez pris connaissance de ce papier
qui reflétait une étude je pense que tu
es publié dans la nature et qu'est ce
que vous en retenir parce qu'ils
semblaient on feint de croire en tout
cas qu'on concrets qu'ils puissent se
transmettent en aérosol l'article a été
publié
c'est pas le premier les deux articles
des dernières semaines sont sortis ou
les chercheurs ont démontré la présence
du virus mais en fait de la rm du virus
donc de son matériel génétique à
différents endroits dans les limites de
soins cependant ce qu'il faut faire très
attention vous avez utilisé le terme se
transmet par là il n'y a aucune preuve
actuellement que ce virus se transmet
par l'air donc sa présence n'est pas
nécessairement un indicateur que c'est
la voie qui va utiliser pour se
transmettre
cependant les experts actuellement ce
qu'on s'entend pour dire c'est que les
aérosols joue sans doute un rôle dans la
transmission
un certain niveau on en a parlé beaucoup
parlent par les semaines passent et que
les miséreux seuls six joueurs ont
certainement pas un rôle aussi important
que le rôle du contact des bouclettes
parce que quelque part c'est en quantité
et en fréquence d'émission par une
personne infectée qui est beaucoup plus
faible
moi j'ai trouvé ces seize la façon de
l'article a été repris aujourd'hui dans
les journaux ça m'a plu surprise parce
que deux points de vue scientifique j'ai
trouvé que ces résultats étaient en
réalité une excellente nouvelle
je m'explique dans les partis qui ont
sorti récemment
les chercheurs mesure justement la rn du
virus dans les chambres d'hôpital à
différents endroits dans l'article de
l'équipe de chine c'est par exemple où
les où les gens
passé médical se déshabillent se change
tout les concentrations qui retrouve
sont extrêmement faibles
on parle d'un virus par mètre cube d'air
jusqu'à peu près 10 dos tres virus par
mètre cube d'air
sauf que samedi c'est que soient les
endroits où les champions étaient pris
applique vraiment bien les
recommandations au niveau de la
ventilation parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que quand particules est émise par
quelqu'un qui est malade on parle
beaucoup des gouttières des projets bon
il va voir aussi particules très petit
de quelques microns qui elles vont s'en
aller dans leur pays ils ont une
destinée éventuelle de parcourir de très
longues distances ces particules
leurrons pas rester là à attendre si la
ventilation fonctionne bien et vont être
expulsés de la pièce vivons peut
s'accumuler dans la pièce donc que les
experts disent en ce moment c'est que
s'il y aura des aérosols dans la
transmission de cette maladie là ça va
avoir lieu probablement dans les
endroits très mal ventilée très peuplée
très confiné et l'oeil ça pourrait jouer
un rôle de façon un peu plus important
chose certaine
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de preuve que
les aérosols joue un rôle dans la
transmission de la maladie
nous on étudie aussi aux laboratoires on
essaie de voir un peu c'est quoi le
comportement de sol et le chou mais mais
de le trouver dans l'air c'est pas la
preuve que ça se transmet par l'air
faire bien attention de ses complètement
normes de trouver ce virus est dans
l'air connaît plein de gens effectifs
sont présents mais est ce que ces études
là où ces informations-là qui pousse les
autorités a suggéré le port du masque
pour diminuer au maximum les risques
parce qu'on dit ou sur l'arctique que
les concentrations de matériel génétique
était généralement peu élevés dans les
lieux publics les immeubles résidentiels
les supermarchés ce swap est rassurant
parce qu'on dit qu'il faut porter le
masque
par contre justement vous avez évoqué
les airs de changement du personnel de
santé
là les airs au sol chargés en virus
peuvent se retrouver à ce niveau en
suspension dans l'air quand les
soignants se dit alors comme on sait que
du personnel de santé qui peut être
contaminé
quelqu'un qui les sort peut être
l'inquiétude je veux me protéger je
comprends imaginez-vous le camp mesure
un virus dans l'air ok à partir de ce
matériel génétique si je fais le
parallèle avec les bactéries par exemple
qu'on les retrouve dans la moi si je
compte une bactérie au niveau de son
matériel génétique et si je mesure aussi
par culture j'habite chez ma mille fois
moins par culture ok donc ce qu'on
pourra interroger les témoins clos
beaucoup d'organismes et que son mari
banques sont morts sans l'endommager
donc si on se dit qu'il ya peu près 1 à
10 virus par mètre cube d'air
toto donc leur génétique qui leur génome
sont là on peut imaginer qu'un homme -
de rôle par mètre cube d'air au final
donc les concentrations sont dans les
milieux de soins dans les articles qui
ont été publiés ce titre est quand vous
parlez du mans ferrando wire le masque
le yap a pour objectif de se protéger
contre les aérosols you projectif de
nous empêcher des limites
la contamination roman donc
éventuellement dans les épiceries tout
ça s'il y avait plus de chances qu'on
contamine avec des gouttelettes avec la
salive avec les mains à la bouche ou
chaudes objet parce qu'on va toucher que
des petites particules dans l'air c'en
est très très loin dans un grand milieu
comme l'extérieur après supermarché par
exemple dans le fasses quelque part il
ya d'autres objectifs ses rapports avec
alors merci beaucoup madame chen